foreign
[Music]
s in a moment you'll hear a woman who
was born in 1878 talk about her
experiences as a child in the 1880s now
this is part two and if you have not
listened to part one yet I will leave a
link in the description in this segment
Mrs Collins gives a very interesting
description of her visit to the area now
known as Beverly Hills back in those
days it was simply called The Hamilton
Ranch and it was primarily used to grow
lima beans it was not until 1906 when a
group of oil Prospectors renamed the
area of Beverly Hills after which began
the construction of the famous Beverly
Hills Hotel as seen here in this
photograph from 1912. later on the
recording Mrs Collins speaks more about
her childhood in Los Angeles and lastly
she gives a very detailed account of her
father Cameron Tung who was born in 1825
and became the mayor of Los Angeles in
1882. so without any more delay let us
get into this amazing first-hand account
of History the date of the recording is
November 26 1964.
well anyhow when I was a little girl
about eight
I guess eight or nine years old the
whole of practically the whole at least
two-thirds of Beverly Hills was owned by
a two-man one was called Hamel and one
was called denka
and it was an enormous dairy farm right
down to where the little park is down
here now opposite the Beverly Hills
Hotel there was nothing but dirt roads
absolutely nothing and my father was the
lawyer for them so the great treat was
that sometimes when he had to come out
and see them he would come out in the
Buckboard and I don't suppose any of you
know what a buck board is is a very
uncomfortable little wagon with a high
seat to two people on it no rubber tires
and a horse and you bumped along these
awful roads well I thought it was lovely
then with great ruts and we used to come
out and would take us practically an
hour or maybe an hour and a half to
drive out here from Third Street you
know on really really awful roads and
then we get here
and uh I don't know whether it was
Hamill or dinker my father would be
cooped up with him in the office while
they went through the returns and what
the thing was doing and the various
legal things he wanted my father to look
into and they turned me loose and they
were enormous Pig size filthy dirty
Pig's eyes were in those days you know
it seemed to be the thing the pigs would
not happen unless they wallowed in filth
and mud and dirt and these were just in
their Prime if that's what they wanted
and then he had enormous herds of cows
they used to make all their butter by
hand and and they had huge dairies and
great big flat tins well I don't can't
tell you how big round they were and
these were on shelves and they put the
milk in those flat tins for the cream to
rise that's the way they worked in those
days then they'd skim off the cream and
the butter was all churned by hand so
that naturally when we went home we took
some of this lovely lovely fresh butter
but I always loved cream and they turned
me loose when nobody was looking I'd
find my way into the dairy where the
cream was rising and I'd stop at the top
pan and I worked my way right down to
the bottom pan and as I went I dragged
my finger across the cream and lick it
and lick it until I had been every pan
on the whole plate nobody knew but me
and that was my day outing with my
father and it was gorgeous and that I
always wanted to go when you'd say to me
would you like to go out to the farmer
and the Thinker and the sofa farm and
I'd say oh I'd love it
because I'd lick all their cream
and now of course it's the smartest
place in this part of the world to live
and I must say one of the most expensive
and they say if you live here they don't
have white lines down the street to show
you which way the traffic should be
moving but the lines are made with white
Urban because the Beverly Hills people
wouldn't understand it it was just paint
and I live in the Beverly Hills Hotel
which I really love
and but it's very expensive way to live
but very comfortable but when I
sometimes look out and think how I knew
it when it was a dairy farm and the
pig's thighs with horses and how I used
to lick the cream it rather makes me
laugh to think what I did then and what
I'm paying now to look out the window
with a spoonful of cream I could have
bought the whole of the farm
in those days what they charge me now
for a teaspoon full of cream
so there we are
now it's just about ready to warm up you
see turn it off then then what do I do
come on chill right
say something to it what can I say it's
all right now it's going now you can
start what do I say well
third of July was my birthday I was then
four years old and my second brother
Casey was a beautiful boy he was and
very fair with big blue eyes and we were
all in the garden and they had fireworks
firecrackers which came in little
packages brought to us from Chinatown by
our Chinese cook and we had punks then
to set them off because I wasn't allowed
to have them too precious so
um Kates we had these firecrackers oh I
must tell you he was such a beautiful
boy and he had a deep dimple in his chin
which he had until the day he died and
he was setting off these firecrackers
and I was a great admirer of his and I
said to him and I suppose a broken
little childish voice I like a dimple
like yours and he said where and I put
my little finger on my cheek and I said
here and believe it or not but I must
have been very stoic he took that red
hot Punk and put it on my little tiny
cheek and made a place which turned into
a great big blister my mother was away
ill and when she came back I had the
most tremendous scar you've ever seen in
your life
and I still have it but it's quite small
it's grown over by fat and whatnot I
guess anyhow that was that and whenever
cakes we used to be very he was about
well he was about over eight years old
then because he was four years older
than I was and whenever he used to want
to be rude to me my mother would look at
him and say how can you talk to her like
that look how you disfigured her that
was that
so anyhow
I don't know whether I told you about Mr
Messmer in those days we call the people
that ran the shops Mr Mesmer and Mr
vandalik and Mr whatnot he had the shop
I told you where we bought all of our
shoes and he amassed quite a lot of
money so when they started to build what
Santa viviana's Cathedral the Roman
Catholic cathedral which now stands in
Main Street between first and second I
think
and a wonderful old building really they
came to him and asked him for a large
donation remember there were very few
people here then but most of them were
Roman Catholics and they gave generously
so he promised a very large donation
but when
the casino they came to collect the
money he had changed his mind and he
wasn't going to give it he gave much
smaller one well the story that went
around Los Angeles was if you notice
over the the particle the cathedral are
three large black letters d o m
which I believe are over most of the
doors of most of the Roman Catholic
Cathedrals it means something in Latin
I'm afraid I forgot what it means and
everybody very few most of the people
knew but they all laughed and said do
you know what happened
Mesmer refused to give the money so when
they finished the cathedral they put
d-o-m-o the front doors and that stands
for damn oh Mesmer
I love that
true my father told me that story
I've come to the conclusion
that my dear niece Rowena is nothing
more or less than a slave driver
I thought I had finished with this
business
I told her all about myself and my
brothers when we were little and now she
wants to know all about my father well
my father was born in 1825
and Berry Hill Culpepper County on a
magnificent estate owned by his father
Colonel John Tom who at that time was
Senator from Virginia United States
senator from Virginia
he graduated from the University of
Virginia
the University was founded exactly in
the same year that my father was born
but he didn't go to school there
naturally he had to wait a few years
so he and a friend of his called Skinner
decided that they'd like to come to
California
and seek their fortunes
and be away from everything and
everybody and see a new life
so they joined one of these colored
wagon things I suppose very much like
you see on this radio and the television
and things
and they started out now my father was
very
handsome he was nearly six feet two very
slender beautiful blue eyes always gay
always Charming as the various lives
that have been written about him have
have mentioned
well they came out and after I don't
know how long they ran into a band of
Friendly Indians
they were with them for some days and my
father in his young days like I suppose
all Virginians were was a very fine
Horseman otherwise well how could they
have got any place if they weren't
and he had his own horse with him which
I imagine was a very fine horse
and the chief
of the tribe invited him
to run a race
well my father accepted and he won the
race
and as a prize the chief wanted to
present him with his daughter
which my father politely and courteously
refused wouldn't it have been marvelous
I would have been an Indian imagine I
was as Fair as a lily wouldn't I have
been an Indian
so uh he refused and the Indian lady or
daughter or whatever you choose to call
her remained with her father and I've
often thought that maybe that old Indian
did that on purpose and lost the race
because he wanted to get rid of the gal
naturally they have millions of them
well they continued and they landed in
the northern part of the estate they had
horrible things happen to them very
awful hardships all the way and then he
landed in the northern part of the
estate we had many adventures and did
many things never found a bit of gold
and then he settled up in Marysville
and where he met my
the mother of what was my to be my
mother
who was my grandmother and she was the
most beautiful beautiful lady so was my
mother my mother was lovely to look at
she was there with the biggest blue eyes
I've ever seen and she had great
intelligence which after living for many
years with my father and being taught by
him I expect she became most most
intellectual
will anyhow
he he lived up there for many years and
did all sorts of things
and then he moved down to Los Angeles
and he had his office he was quite young
then and he had his office up near the
Plaza
I think that's about the only part of
Los Angeles where there were buildings
where you cared could have an office and
he he did what they called in those days
he hung out his shingle and he was going
to be a lawyer
and he used to walk home to lunch in
those days there were no restaurants you
either walked home to lunch or you
didn't have lunch
and he'd walk home for lunch and he
built the house that we were all born in
but at that time it was much smaller
than it was afterwards because as we
came along he had to add on a
tremendously big Wing extra bedrooms and
all sorts of things and he lived in what
they called batched with an old friend
of his or a great friend of his
and uh they'd come home to lunch they
had a housekeeper who had two girls and
they did all the work and all the
housework and all the cooking and
everything
my father was always given up to the day
I imagined that he died of playing
practical jokes he always did to me but
always And he as he came home that this
special day to lunch
he walked down what was then Main Street
no roads I expect just muddy ruts in the
middle and and sidewalks with wood
across
and as he came past the plaza as a rule
there were men there sitting on boxes
who auctioned off land now the land
as far as I suppose what would now be
9th Street head houses on each side
sparse houses sparsely in between
and after that it was nothing but open
Open Fields no roads no anything just
real real country
and there's a was a man that sat in the
plaza and auctioned off this land
anybody could buy it that wanted to buy
it and as my father came through
the man was auctioning it off and as he
came through he threw over his shoulder
oh I've been a dollar and a half and
went on thinking he was so funny came
home and when his friend that batched
with him Broderick William Broderick
came home he said cam you bought an
awful lot of land today and he said oh I
didn't buy any land and never bought an
acre oh but you did he said you know
when you said a dollar and a half you
had an awful lot of land knocked down to
you for a down half an acre nothing but
feels an Open Country and no roads and
what are you going to do well my father
had to keep it and he had for many many
years until the they started developing
but he always said he was land poor he
had all this land nobody bought it
nobody built on it and it was just that
now where the Standard Oil building
stands on the corner of Hope and only
Olympic he owned from there right up to
Figueroa Street
I can't tell you I really can't tell you
how far it was or what distance it was
but the only thing that remains to
remind us that that was once his
property
is an alley at the back of the Standard
Oil building and it's called Pembroke
alley and my father named this little
strip of land after Pembroke who by way
was the apple of his eye well that was
that
and
I can't think you I can't tell you I
can't think of anything else to tell you
about what he did I only know that
everybody adored him
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
enough
[Music]